ty's one of our favorite over on um
twitter you guys should go follow ty she
writes for occupy democrats by the way
so go check out her articles at occupy
denver we've actually featured a couple
of her articles here
on the tony michaels podcast because i
think she's wrote about those oath
keepers that i keep talking about i keep
talking about the oath keepers they keep
talking about the proud boys they keep
talking about roger stone and i keep
talking about that god damn decision
made out in california by car judge
carter
about john eastman's emails and how they
were not protected by attorney client
privilege because john eastman and
donald trump committed a conspiracy to
obstruct an official proceeding
that is why judge carter decided that
those are criminal and that is why
they're not protected
by attorney-client privilege a federal
judge has ruled
that donald trump and john eastman
committed crimes
conspiracy to obstruct
congress official proceeding is the
actual charge
or the actual crime that he accuses them
of in his in his judgment
on
the fact that these emails that they
were they were planning the cheeto dust
kangaroo coup are not protected by
attorney client privilege
but that is significant and the reason
why that's significant is again and and
when questioning marjorie taylor green
the petitioner's lawyer even brought up
martial law which i thought oh man maybe
he's gonna come in
here with some real evidence
some real evidence
because there is actual evidence out in
the open in the public that we have
that shows that the oath keepers were
waiting
they were waiting
on an order from someone
to
order the qrf which is the stockpile
weapons across the potomac in virginia
to bring them across the river
so that way they were armed
that way they could commit or commit a
coup
by donald trump declaring martial law
and deputizing the oath keepers
stewart rhodes was in charge of that qrf
or that stockpile weapons he was waiting
for the order
and it just so happens that one of his
lieutenants who has pled guilty to
conspiracy of sedition
which is important when you talk about
the qrf and the stash of weapons
he was protecting roger stone he was
standing right next to roger stone the
entire
the entire time the insurrection was
happening on january 6.
now it's known that roger stone has a
personal connection with the president
and probably has a personal line
with the president where he could
either call or text him i don't know i
would imagine that roger stone maybe
even had burners on him that day who
knows i guess maybe we'll find out in a
court of law one of these days
but also that is what is significant
is that
stuart rhodes the founder of the oath
keepers
who whose lieutenant was protecting
standing next to roger stone the entire
time the insurrection was happening
met with enrique tario
the day before and the context there is
that they met in a parking garage in
washington dc where enrique tario was
ordered not to be it was unlawful for
him to be in the city of washington dc
at that moment
and there was a a protest where he had
burned a sign off of a church they tore
a sign down off a church and they'd
ordered him out of the city but he came
in anyways to meet with stuart rhodes
the founder of the oak keepers where his
lieutenant
would be standing next to roger stone
waiting for orders apparently from
someone
to give to stewart rhodes that martial
law had been that had been declared
and that the stack stockpile weapons
could be brought across the potomac
to stop those antifa and black lives
matter and even marjorie taylor green
in her testimony here in open court
brings up antifa and black lives matter
that racist [ __ ]
of course they could they they do this
[ __ ] where they conflate these two
issues
and the reason why is because they
wanted black lives matter and antifa
there that day but they weren't but they
wanted them there they wanted so bad for
antiva and black lives matter to commit
violence
so that way it was very easy for the
president united states at the time the
cheeto dust mobster grandpa poopy pants
himself donald trump
to declare martial law and to deputize
the oath keepers so they could arrest
members of congress
and it is very important to know
that stewart road and stuart rhodes and
enrique tario met the night before
and the reason why it's super super
super duper
significant is because the proud boys
were supposed to be the security force
that was going to be next to roger stone
that day
but they switched it for some reason for
some reason the proud boys decided they
wouldn't protect roger stone that the
oath keepers were i wonder if it's
because the proud boys didn't have the
stockpile weapons it was the oath
keepers who had the possibility of
bringing the qrf across the potomac
but the reason why also that the proud
boys are significant in that they
were in cahoots with roger stone is one
of the people that have charged an
indictment with enrique tario
is another lieutenant but of the proud
boys and he has pled guilty
to the conspiracy listen to this
the conspiracy
to an obstruct and official
proceeding
that is very very very important
very important in this case when we
watch
that that a judge a federal judge in
california judge carter says that john
eastman
and donald trump were committing a crime
that's why they're not protected
by attorney-client privilege and the
crime that he thinks they've committed
that would not protect their
attorney-client privilege is the
conspiracy to obstruct an official
proceeding
and we have the proud boys
pleading guilty to that exact charge
this is not this is not
this is not
um
hard to understand
it's not hard to follow the bouncing
ball here we know this out in public now
and marjorie taylor green has done
nothing more today
than to maybe maybe keep herself on the
ballot but only to reveal to us
the real plans
of january 6 she lays it out when she's
asked about martial law
and of course they tried to cover their
tracks of course they did of course she
made videos the president united states
made a video
in the rose garden trying to cover his
tracks when they knew it wasn't going to
work and when they knew it wasn't going
to work is when mike pence
did refuse to leave the capitol
when he refused to leave and he refused
to go along with the cheeto dust
kangaroo coup and his
his role in it
mike pence refused
to not do the thing that he was that he
was constitutional constitutionally set
out to do was his duty
was to preside over the proceeding
where the states would certify the vote
that they had already certified
folks
all's mike pence was doing was opening
up the oscar envelope and reading the
results
this objection [ __ ] that she's talking
about oh democrats have objected before
it is the right of a member of congress
to vote to object to a certification she
is correct
that is your right you do have that
right as a congressperson
but that doesn't mean that it's going to
happen and just because you have the
right doesn't mean you have an
alternative which is what she was
talking about in one of those videos
that was shown when she didn't recall i
don't recall if that's me i don't know i
my memory just went blank